so you're a billionaire
the problem with being billionaire is
that you make a lot of money
a lot of taxable money that you don't
want the government to get the grubby
little hands on
which is understandable because they'll
probably waste it on things like 61 000
homeless tents you worked for your money
you proved that you were smarter and
more capable than the rest you should be
able to keep your money
so we need a way to hide your wealth
discreetly to reduce your tax burden
you could buy something like a yacht but
as they say the two happiest days of a
man's life is the day he buys a yacht in
the day he sells a yacht they cost a ton
of money to maintain they're huge they
can't go up in value all that much and
they're hardly discreet
real estate is a similar story it's
definitely not portable it doesn't go up
in value that much and it's hard to hide
stocks on the other hand can go to the
moon but stocks are tracked
electronically and fall under the
jurisdiction of governments that can
easily seize your assets
we need a financial instrument that is a
small extremely concentrated store of
wealth that's discrete hard to track
easy to transport and ideally can
skyrocket to the moon
enter fine arts a high-end industry that
the ultra wealthy used to store their
money hide their money move their money
around the world
legally avoid taxes and for the more
shady bunch
launder their dirty money and the way
this opaque industry works may be
shocking
and at the end of the video we're gonna
be giving away a thousand dollars of my
own money directly to one of you
so make sure you stick to the end
[Music]
but none of this matters if you're not a
billionaire and as long time viewers of
this channel know well
if there's one tried and true way to
becoming a billionaire it's by launching
your own business
the problem is the internet is filled
with an endless sea of business gurus
that have never actually started a real
business
fortunately finding that next big thing
to capitalize on has never been easier
thanks to today's video sponsor
trends trends provides you with an
important updates about up and coming
things that need to be on your radar
right now
think of trends as sort of like your
smart friend from 2013.
you know the one that would never shut
up about that thing called bitcoin with
a trends membership you can learn about
emerging technologies before they change
the world
stick to the end to learn more or stop
what you're doing right now pause the
video and get your first week of
transfer just one dollar by going to
trends.co
jake tram the link is in the video
description below
okay great now that you're a billionaire
it's time for step one buying the arts
you can't just buy any art though see
the fine art world is a very exclusive
circle that's made up of only a few
exquisite galleries or dealers where the
art gets sold for the first time
and two major auction houses where art
gets resold for increasingly higher
prices
both take a percentage of how much they
sell the art for the galleries and
dealers are kind of like the federal
reserve the money printer of the united
states
they're the ones who pick who they think
the best up and coming artists are and
sister high status has so much pull in
the art world the artists they promote
end up being the most sought after
artists with the most expensive works
not necessarily because their art is the
most beautiful but because they were the
chosen artists
oh the galleries and dealers kind of
artificially set the value of these
artists
so these are the works of art you want
to buy so you go to the gallery of your
choice pick a piece they don't put the
price on display so you're gonna have to
ask
and when you finalize a price it's time
for step number two
where are you going to store the arts
[Music]
now there are two kinds of ultra wealthy
that buy fine arts
one are the people that genuinely enjoy
art they want to display it proudly in
their home for everyone to see just how
cultured they are
i probably fall more into this category
minus you know the billionaire part
and then you have the ones that purely
see art for what we called it a
financial instrument to grow their money
and get the government's grubby hands
off of their wealth
i can definitely see the appeal of this
camp too so determine which side you're
on for the particular pieces you picked
up
if you want to hang up that beautiful
painting you'll have to pay some sales
tax which sucks
but that is the price one has to pay to
admire beauty
if you don't really care what the
artworks look like you are in luck
because what you can do is purchase the
artwork and have it shipped directly to
what's called a freeport
freeports are a beautiful thing they're
giant warehouses that you can think of
as the physical equivalent of a swiss
bank account
or at least what a swiss bank account
used to be since they're not so private
anymore
anyhow free parts are warehouses where
you can store your newfound art
anonymously so it's invisible to tax
authorities foreign governments without
any taxes like the oldest freeport in
geneva switzerland which is reported to
hold 1.2 million artworks in a dark
locked building valued at an estimated
100 billion dollars
now that you either have your art
displayed in your home or locked away in
a free port
it's time to pump up those numbers i'm
gonna pump those numbers up those are
rookie numbers in this racket
[Music]
r is like any other asset like real
estate or stocks
if you're selling your home and similar
houses in your neighborhood keep selling
for higher and higher prices
that means your house is valued at that
higher price if you own a painting from
one artist and other pieces from that
artist keep selling at higher and higher
prices
while the value of your painting goes up
too at least on paper
and this is where the galleries and
dealers would do most of the work
since most prestigious galleries get the
artists they choose to work exclusively
through them
they can do some pretty cool tricks to
up the value of their art and thus
upping their commission once they sell a
painting to you they can use their
influence to hype up the artist to
create more demand
they can host prestigious exhibits get
influential writers to write about them
they can auction off some other pieces
of art and have their friends bid on
them to increase their value
things like this that artificially or
actually get the value of the painting
to go up
the higher the better and then it's time
for the moment you've all been waiting
for
realizing those gains
[Music]
you have a couple options here let's say
in this scenario you had a stellar year
where you got a hundred million dollar
income from one of those projects that a
typical billionaire has going on
great right wrong because you're in the
highest tax bracket you're going to be
paying a disgusting 37
income tax and that's just federal now
it's not exactly 37
and billionaires probably wouldn't
accept this money as income but to keep
it simple we'll assume that this is the
case
which means that 37 million dollars of
your life is going towards uncle sam
more than what most people can ever even
conceive of much or less make
we obviously can't have that now so
here's what we're gonna do let's say you
bought a painting for 10 million dollars
a few years back
and today is now worth a nice 50 million
dollars you five
extra money on paper doesn't mean you're
going to be able to find a buyer for 50
mil but that's what you can claim on
paper
these numbers are not that out of the
ordinary by the way being that this
leonardo da vinci painting's over
million recently and of course we have
the infamous people nft that sold for
69.3 million
so you put 10 mil into this financial
instrument now you have 50 mil on paper
and you have that disgusting 37 mil tax
bill staring at you in the face
well what you can do is donate that
painting to a museum
and then you can write off that 50 ml
donation to reduce your 100 million
taxable income it's not that simple
though so bear with me for a sec
this is a good time to say that i'm not
an accountant or any fiduciary
professional whatsoever
and if you're a billionaire you have
many accountants so why are you
listening to me
to be able to claim this painting is now
worth 50 million dollars you have to get
it appraised by a professional and have
them certified that's worth that much
a professional that might be a friend of
yours or friends of the dealer
who all have incentives to make you
happy
so you get that independent professional
to appraise your masterpiece at 50 mil
then you can donate it to the museum and
then you can write off that 50 mil
not quite see you made a hundred mil
this year your donation is 50 mil
but the tax code only allows you to
deduct no more than 30
of your income from donations so out of
that 50 mil donation you can only deduct
30 mil of that
leaving your new taxable income at 70
mil saving you millions of dollars that
otherwise would have got to greedy uncle
sam
but do not fret because that remaining
20 ml of your donation that you couldn't
deduct
you can spread out that deduction over
the next five years
combine that art donation with a few
other tax strategies and uncle sam gets
pennies on the dollar
again not professional advice so in the
end you keep more of your money the
museum gets a work of art that they
couldn't afford on their own
you get your name displayed next to the
painting for that status the prestige of
the artist and dealer
goes up and literally everyone is happy
thanks to a few strokes of paint on
canvas
or a banana duct tape onto a wall or
whatever but let's say you don't need a
giant tax deduction this year
but you need the cashless tied up in
this painting you got that's gone way up
in value
well then it's time to take it to
auction
taking an artwork to auction can be
really exciting the great thing about
auctions is that you can use crowd
psychology to your advantage
people bidding will make other people
want to bid and not just for the
products but to feed their ego and to
beat the other bidders
combine that with the scarcity of an
auction and you have the perfect recipe
for bad financial decisions on the part
of the buyer good financial decision for
you
but jake what if people don't bid up the
price very high don't you worry because
another great thing about auctions is
that the auction house can arrange a
reserve price guarantee
they do this by finding an interested
buyer in advance that agrees to pay a
reserve price if the auction doesn't
meet that amount
undisclosed to the public and in
exchange if the auction goes over that
reserve price this person gets a portion
of the proceeds above that guarantee
but wait there's more see in any typical
sale of a house for example
the names of the buyers and sellers go
on paper but in auctions the identity of
both are typically concealed
sometimes the auction house might not
even know who the seller is
thanks to this privacy theoretically you
can even bid up your own auctions
and once the auction starts that's where
the fun begins the auctioneer plays an
important role
the right one can really up the bidding
the wrong one can ruin everything
one cool trick they pull is called
chandelier bidding where the auctioneer
will literally pretend to point at bids
in the room when in reality they're
often pointing to nothing more than
light fixtures
and hopefully if there's enough hype
around the piece if you listen to the
piece
at the right time you'll walk away with
a fat stack of cash that isn't taxed as
ordinary
income mind you but as long-term capital
gains tax which is a lot lower than
ordinary income
and boom whatever route you choose
everyone wins the gallery and dealers
when you win the artist wins the auction
house wins and the museum wins
and if you decide to keep the painting
it can still come in handy
again there aren't a lot of assets out
there that can hold 450 million dollars
worth of value in the size of a painting
completely anonymously besides crypto
which is volatile
fine art makes for a great addition to
that emergency vault along with some
cash precious metals passports some
crypto hard wallets along with jewelry
which is in kind of the same boat
like these beautiful innovative jacob
and co astronomia gravitational triple
axis tourbillon watches that sell for
anywhere from half a mil to over a mil
or they're mystery tourbillon watches
that sell anywhere from 1.6 mil to 2 mil
where else can you find assets like this
that hold this much value in the size of
a painting or wristwatch outside of
crypto
and one convenient thing about jewelry
is that you don't have to declare the
value of your jewelry like you do for
cash when flying
and back to artwork you can even take
out a loan against your artwork to avoid
having to sell it which again you need
to get
a praise for spy pro
[Music]
but again none of this matters if you
lack resources
that is where trends comes in arguably
the most resourceful platform on the
internet for entrepreneurs
where learning about the next big thing
is as easy as opening up an email
their army of analysts dig through
millions of searches scouring the
deepest parts of the web and search for
emerging data on interesting topics that
hold the potential to change the world
when the trends team find something that
needs to be on your radar they'll send
you a signal so you can learn more about
it
signals about everything from slack apps
to vertical farming
take chris for example one of trent's
many success stories he built his third
party logistics company sen eats
because he read trenz's article about
the a to z of the rise of
anything as a service industry thanks to
the help of the trends community chris
has already grown the business to tens
of thousands of orders
every month or considered norwreck when
trent said in a reckon email about the
booming indoor plant industry he didn't
hesitate soon after receiving the signal
nerec launched his very own direct to
consumer indoor plant startup
after announcing the project in the
trends community he collected feedback
and got to work
40 days later he raised 1.5 million
dollars in funding
still not convinced trent even holds
live q and a's with industry leaders to
review their secrets so you can learn
from the masters
head over to trends.co jake trent or
click the link in the video description
below to get your first week of trends
for just one dollar
there's no commitment no catch and you
can cancel any time again that's
trends.co slash jake tran
[Music]
do you want to win a thousand dollars
here's what you have to do number one
subscribe to this channel and number two
submit to me a video idea for this
channel that you think would go viral
and get at least a million views you can
submit that video idea with the link
below and that is literally it
if i end up choosing your video idea and
your title etc i will be sending you
a thousand dollars of my own money and
your idea will be forever cemented on
this channel you can submit your video
idea with the link below just make sure
you read all the instructions you can
submit as many ideas as you want just
don't spam it or do anything stupid
if you do you will be banned if you're
not aware we've recently done videos on
how china is enslaving africa in debt
where we talked to an actual person
that's in slave countries in debt before
meet america's hedge fund billionaires
the apex predators of wall street
why haven't we seen hyperinflation yet
where we talked to peter schiff so if
these videos sound interesting to you
consider subscribing and turning on that
notification bell
shout out to salvatore for following me
on instagram every single week i'll be
following back one of you guys and
giving you guys a shout out in the new
video so make sure you follow me at
jaketrend.io and one final shout out to
a youtuber named iraq he is an
incredibly entertaining youtuber to
watch
and i just met him a few days ago super
chill guy super genuine guy
and he is the person responsible for you
guys getting free money from me
and instagram shout outs you can
subscribe to his channel with the link
below and let him know that i sent you
that's gonna wrap it up for this video
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you